à l'école comme sur internet on n'a pas
arrêté de vous mentir si on prend qu'une
partie de cet ensemble sont cardinal il
doit être forcément plus petits
l'ensemble de toutes tes phrases
possible et un ensemble qui est plus
grand que l'ensemble des non braves de
tous les podcasts sur une thématique
il existe un infini intermédiaires qui
serait strictement plus grand que
l'infini des nombres entiers noté à
l'aise 0 est strictement plus petit que
celui de l'infini des nombres réels
noter deux puissances alès 0 ne peut pas
y avoir dans ton corentin fini tout un
film grand x est toujours strictement
plus petit que l'autre infinie p 2 x
sauf que sauf que ce qu'on ne vous a pas
toujours clairement dit c'est que tous
ces raisonnements ne sont valables que
dans la théorie standard des
mathématiques à savoir la théorie z fc
dès que l'on passe à la théoriser dave
c'est à dire si on omet l'axiome du
choix et deviennent déjà un petit peu
erronée et lorsque l'on passe à la
logique inflationniste ils perdent
complètement tout leur sens c'est comme
si vous avez grandi toute votre vie en
pensant que le petit déjeuner était un
repas un peu spécial pas complet c'est à
dire on mangeait pas de stock de burgers
au petit déjeuner et qu'en partant à
l'étranger nous vous rendiez compte
qu'en fait c'est possible et que ce que
vous croyez n'était qu'une conséquence
de votre tradition de votre entourage de
votre éducation
mais avant de découvrir comment on peut
vivre tout aussi bien voire mieux dans
un pays différent
revenons-en au mathématicien georg
cantor et à la découverte slash
invention des cardinaux
quand il commença à sonder l'infini
kantor se convaincre que si on pouvait
construire une belle action entre un
ensemble x un sous-ensemble de y
c'est à dire si l'on pouvait relier tout
élément de x un élément de y sans
qu'aucun élément de les grecs ne soit
relié à plusieurs éléments de x alors on
prouver par là que x était plus petit
que y ont dit qu'il existe une injection
de x vers y en particulier quant au
refus convaincu que si l'on montre ainsi
que x est plus petit que y mais aussi
que x est plus grand que y
alors on pouvait en déduire qu'il existe
une direction entre x y
c'est à dire intuitivement que x ou y
ont la même taille ou pour être plus
puristes qu'ils ont le même cardinal ce
théorème est aujourd'hui connu sous le
nom de théorème de kantor bernstein oui
mais est-ce que cet horaire vrai pour le
prouver kantor fit appel à l'axiome du
choix alors je vais pas rentrer dans les
détails de la preuve
mais sachez que kantor utilisa le
théorème 2 rbds et l'eau pour pouvoir
analyser les cardinaux à l'aide des
ordinands grâce otto rahn 2 rbds et le
canton réussi à prouver que si x est
plus grand que y/y plus grand que x
alors x c'est le noeud cardinal que y
les détails importants toujours est il
que kantor fou persuadé que les
cardinaux correspondait bel et bien à
des mesures détail des ensembles en
particulier si je prends deux ensemble
alors forcément 20 des ensembles un
cardinal strictement plus grand que
l'autre l'autre un cardinal strictement
plus grand que l'un ou les deux ensemble
ont le même cardinal
cependant tout ceci n'est valable que si
l'on a postulé l'action du choix or
l'action du choix comme on l'a vu dans
l'épisode 15 n'a rien de si évident en
fait sans l'action du choix il est
impossible de toujours comparer les
cardinaux de deux ensembles différents
il est même possible dès lors que pour
deux ensembles x et y
il n'existe pas d'injection de x vers y
ni d'injection de y dans x autrement dit
il est désormais possible qu'il n'y ait
pas de preuve que le cardinal 2x est
inférieur ou égal à celui de y ou que le
cardinal de y est inférieur ou égal à
celui de x autrement dit les cardinaux
de x et y peuvent être incomparable on
dit que la relation d'ordre sur les
cardinaux ne forment plus qu'une
relation d'ordre partiel et ça ça
suggère que les cardinaux ne mesure plus
vraiment les tailles d infini alors dans
cf le théorème de cantorbery steiner est
vrai si le cardinal 2x est inférieure ou
égale est supérieur ou égal à celui de y
alors les cardinaux de x et y sont égaux
la preuve est alors presque constructive
mais pas tout à fait pour prouver le
théorème de cantor bernstein dans z nous
faut un espèce de super pouvoirs il nous
faut être en quelque sorte capable de
savoir si nous chaîne d'éléments est
fini ou infini
d'un coup d'un seul essai ça contraste
avec la logique un sioniste
constructiviste a priori on connaît un
élément de la chaîne
mais pour savoir si cette chaîne va être
infinie ou non il nous faudrait suivre
les éléments de la chaîne les uns après
les autres et a priori on ne pouvait pas
vérifier que cette chaîne continue à
l'infini en parcourant uniquement les
éléments de la chaîne les uns après les
autres je vais pas entrer dans les
détails de la preuve du théorème de
cantorbery stein dans un déf
pour en savoir plus je vous invite à
aller voir ce super article de peter
doig et john conway alors on pourrait
croire que du coup la logique
inflationniste se restreint à tout ce
qui est uniquement fini tout ce qu'un
ordinateur est capable de manipuler
prêtes ou en pratique nos ordinateurs
sont des objets finis et ne traite que
des quantités finies de données
cependant logique intuition liste on va
d'ordinaire s'autoriser considérer des
ordinateurs avec des espaces mémoire
infinie ce que les mathématiciens
elle des machines de tueries l'énoncé du
théorème de kantor bernstein devient
alors légèrement différent dès que l'on
passe à logique intuition nist la
question est la suivante étant donné une
injection de x dont y c'est à dire un
programme informatique qui prend
n'importe quel aimant 2x et produit un
élément de y
de sorte que deux éléments de x ne
produit jamais le même élément de y
et étant donné un autre programme
informatique qui fait l'injection de y
temps x est ce qu'il est possible de
construire un troisième algorithme qui
sera capable de faire une pige hexion de
x ou y
étrangement la réponse est non le
théorème de kantor bernstein est
désormais faut en logique intuition nist
autrement dit la relation sur les
cardinaux des infinis n'est même plus
une relation d'ordre mais il ya bien
pire encore on peut désormais construire
des sous-ensembles non finis d'ensemble
des anti naturel qu'ils ne soient pas
obligés ctions avec l'ensemble des anti
naturel
je ne vais pas entrer dans les détails
mais l'idée de construire un ensemble
d'outils naturel qu'une machine de
turing ne peut pas calculer et ça ça
peut se faire en vertu du problème de
l'arrêt donc thomas vous a parlé dans
cette superbe vidéo de patience
autrement dit en logique intuition nist
on peut désormais construire des
ensembles dentier naturel indénombrables
quand le sens où ils ne pourront pas
être mis en bij et ctions avec
l'ensemble des entiers naturels ou avec
l'ensemble tn premiers nombres naturel
pire encore en mathématiques
constructive
on peut définir un nombre réel comme
étant une machine de turing qui est
étant donné un entier n nous calcule la
énième décimales du nombre ray sauf qu'à
l'aide d'une machine de turing dites
universelles
on peut lister toutes les machines de
turing c'est-à-dire associés à chaque
machine de turing un entier naturel donc
l'ensemble des machine de turing est en
billes action avec l'ensemble des
sentiers naturels l'ensemble des nombres
réels et donc en billes action avec un
ensemble de machine de turing qui est un
sous ensemble de l'ensemble de toutes
les machines de turing qui lui est en
direction avec l'ensemble des antiennes
naturel
vous le voyez venir l'ensemble des
nombre réel est ambigu action avec un
sous-ensemble de l'ensemble des entiers
naturels
cependant rassurez vous je sais pas si
ça va vous rassurer nombre réel de la
logique inflationniste reste
indénombrables dans la mesure où il est
impossible de les mettre en gage
élections avec l'ensemble de tous les
anti naturel
pire encore il existe des sous-ensembles
d'ensemble fini qui ne sont pas finis
pour comprendre ça il est bon de revenir
à la définition de ce qu'est un ensemble
fini ensemble fini est un ensemble qui
est ambigu réaction avec l'ensemble des
aides premiers nombres entiers naturels
strict en positif en particulier comme
vous y attendent l ensemble qui ne
contient que 1 est un ensemble fine
construisons maintenant le sous-ensemble
x 2 1 qui contient un si et seulement si
un certain problème indécidable est vrai
alors il n'existe pas de façon
algorithmique de prouver si un
appartient à x et du coup n'existe pas
de façon algorithmique de construire une
bille gestion entre x est un ensemble
fini romandie x n'est pas finie pire
encore x n'est clairement pas infinies
dans ce sens on ne peut pas le mettre en
direction avec un ensemble un film x est
donc ni fini ni infini en logique
intuition liste il existe des ensembles
qui ne sont ni fini ni infini
en clair quand on passe à la logique
intuition liste la notion de taille
c'est un sacré désordre
ça reste une relation d'équivalence mais
ce n'est absolument plus une relation
d'ordre et ça n'a rien à voir avec la
notion intuitive de ta et d infiniment
logique intuition liste
le cardinal
mesure pas la taille des ensembles alors
je suis sûr que ça donne envie à
beaucoup de platonicien parmi vous de
rejeter les mathématiques constructive
mais à mon sens ce que cela montre
surtout c'est à quel point on envie de
nous recroqueviller sur les vérités
mathématiques que l'on pense avoir
démontré à l'instar de ces géomètres du
19e qui rejetait l'existence de
géométrie non euclidienne je conseille
de l'intuition liste est le suivant ne
nous enfermons pas dans des convictions
dont on comprend mal les fondements tout
au contraire un vrai scientifique un
vrai mathématicien devrait être
enthousiasmé par toutes les nouvelles
structures et tous les nouveaux objets
qu'offrent les mathématiques intuition
aunis on y trouve des théorèmes
absolument merveilleux par exemple tous
les ensembles de réalisme mesurables et
toutes les fonctions ils sont continus
j'invite donc les platonicien parmi vous
à voir les mathématiques constructive
comme un tout autre pays peut-être même
un tout autre univers dont les
traditions les végétations et les
paysages demande qu'à être découverts il
est grand temps de quitter le paradis
que quand on aura créé pour nous et dans
lequel il berthe nous a enfermés
la terre fois j'avais posé la question
est-ce que les maths son invention ou
découvertes et ça m'a permis
d'introduire la notion de logique
intuition nice tu iras la fin notamment
de la vidéo précédente je vous avais dit
quand logique inflationniste le théorème
de valeur intermédiaire n'avait pas de
preuves et ça a dérangé par mal parmi
vous qui semblent croire que le théorème
des valeurs intermédiaires est forcément
vrai
quasiment d'un point de vue physique
alors à ce qu'en physique le drame des
valeurs intermédiaires est vrai on ne
semble vraiment pas évident et pour en
savoir plus je vous invite vraiment
aller voir cette superbe vidéo de vie
sauce où on se rend compte qu'en fait
rien ne se couche jamais il n'y a jamais
de point d'intersection tu tiens entre
les atomes de notre espace temps puisque
ces atomes déjà sont pas des points
locaux et il ya toujours des champs
d'interaction plutôt que des contacts
physiques
le procès de contact physique en fait
c'est une grosse approximations à
l'échelle des électrons ça n'existe pas
et d'ailleurs en pratique quand on fait
des mathématiques appliquées je pense
notamment aux équations aux dérivées
partielles ou un truc du genre
dès que l'on commencé à coder les
nombres sur un ordinateur on va pas
chercher à avoir un point exactement sur
la droite on va plutôt chercher un point
qui est proche de la droite
la notion de proximité beaucoup plus
importante que la notion d'égalité entre
les nombres réels et on a un terme des
valeurs intermédiaires pour cette notion
de proximité
on peut démontrer le théorème suivant si
une courbe traverse une droite alors on
peut construire un point de la courbe
qui est toujours aussi proches que l'on
veut de la droite
donc c'est un petit peu plus alambiqués
à exprimer mais c'est aussi beaucoup
plus proche de ce que les mathématiciens
appliquer ceux qui font des simulations
numériques font réellement en pratique
voilà ce sur quoi j'aimerais attirer
votre attention c'est que certes le
terrain des valeurs intermédiaires n'a
pas de preuves aux logiques intuition
nist mai
le fait qu'il n'ait pas de preuves est
en fait une informations extrêmement
pertinentes pour les praticiens et elle
réveille quelque chose sur la difficulté
du théorème des valeurs intermédiaires
et des nombre réel de façon plus
générale je vous rappelle qu'on
informatique
l'addition des doubles ans qui est la
représentation classique du nombre réel
dans la plupart des langages de
programmation informatique
l'addition des doubles du flottant n'est
pas commutative donc ce ne sont pas des
vrais nombreux réel qu'on utilise en
informatique et je pense qu'il est plus
pertinent de remettre en cause ce que
l'on croit savoir des nombreux réel que
de juste considérer culture de valeurs
intermédiaires et une vérité
indiscutable qu'il faut donner un coup
de froid nous demandent comment est-ce
que l'on peut prouver que racine 42 et
irrationnelle en logique intuition nist
sachant que la preuve par l'absurde est
discutable en fait faut faire attention
il ya deux types de preuve par l'absurde
c'est la preuve d'existence part absurde
qui est rejeté par les intuitions
analystes mais dire que racine carrée de
2 et 10 national comment est ce que vous
pouvez définir ça vraiment qu'est ce que
ça veut dire que racine carrée de 2 et
irrationnel bien ça veut dire que si
jamais quelqu'un arrive a écrit racine
carrée deux camps météo idéale ap / qu
alors en un cataclysme dans les
mathématiques c'est vraiment ça que de
dire qu'un nombre et irrationnel pris en
ce sens la preuve classique que racine
car de dos et irrationnel est exactement
la preuve du fait que dire que racine
car deux de ses cris comme paix sûre
qu'un pic un cataclysme mathématiques ce
qui est rejeté par les anti sionistes
c'est la preuve d'existence pour
l'absurde c'est à dire le raisonnement
selon lequel pour prouver l'existence
d'un objet peut partir de l'hypothèse
selon laquelle cet objet n'existe pas et
en déduire une contradiction et le fait
que ça implique l'existence de l'objet
c'est quelque chose qui est rejeté par
l'intuition liste parce que pour faire
ce raisonnement il faut utiliser le fait
que la négation de la négation d'une
phrase est égal à son affirmation
ça c'est le tiers exclu et le tire lait
cru est rejetée par les anti sionistes
alors je vous dis rejeté faire un petit
peu gaffe c'est à dire que le tir
excluait faut se dire qu'il n'a pas de
preuves qu'ils supposent pas qu'il est
vrai en logique anti sioniste enfin je
tiens juste à signaler que la vidéo
précédente était une caricature du
platonicien
du conte fantaisiste en pratique a bien
sûr différents niveaux vous être plus ou
moins vraies plus ou moins
constructiviste je ne suis même pas sûr
que les deux soient incompatibles on
peut être à la fois constructives et se
dire croire en effet il faut étudier les
machines turing et se placer dans un
autre platonicien où on a des machines
de turenne que vous peut vraiment des
pulls et et al'inverse on peut croire en
certains aspects de la théorie des
élèves par exemple on peut croire aux
élections tout en étant constructiviste
est d'ailleurs l'article de peter boyle
et john conway est un exemple de deux
mathématiciens qui acceptent le tir
exclu mais qui ont quand même quelque
chose de très constructif dans leur
approche des mathématiques
elle espère que vous avez aimé cet
épisode j'aimerais insister sur le fait
que j'ai été très impliqué dans la
description de la logique inflationniste
air beaucoup beaucoup de trucs fascinant
à découvrir sur la logique ou argenté en
logique inflationniste particules vous
invite vraiment aller voir la vidéo du
séminaire donné par andrés pas voir il
si tu t'en vas d'une cerise à princeton
où il donne des bonnes raisons d'être
constructiviste un public de non
constructiviste donc la vidéo est super
bien fait super intéressante il parle
notamment de visiter ensemble ni fini ni
infini ou encore des fonctions qui sont
tout continue des produits sionistes
j'ai omis aussi en lien un excellent
article de blog qu'il avait écrit sur
émail constructive mathy chez nous oui
il parle notamment des nombreux réel en
mathématiques constructive et donc c'est
tout aussi facilement voir plus
facilement une ombre réel classique et
enfin pour les plus motivés on va voir
aussi publié dans american medical
society un article qui correspond à son
séminaire intitulé five studies of
accepting constructive matemale x vous
invite vraiment aller voir ça surtout si
vous avez un certain bagage
mathématiques qui va vous permettre
d'apprécier tout ce dont parle rentrée
faveur si vous avez aimé cet épisode
penser à le leak et à le commenter le
partage et pensez à vous abonner pour ne
pas manquer les futurs épisodes merci au
type heure creuse donc et j'espère que
vous verrez la prochaine fois et on va
se rendre compte que tout ce qui faisait
par un algorithme est faisable par une
machine de turing et réciproquement
c'est ce qu'on appelle la thèse de
church turing pour leur propre pays
deux extrêmes les salles avait dans
notre animatrice très in de vélines